Athene c2h4 molar mass of 28.1 grams per
mole may be prepared by the dehydration
of ethanol c2h5oh molar mass forty six
point one grams per mole using a solid
catalyst a set up for the lab synthesis
is shown in the diagram above the
equation for the dehydration reaction
issue is given below so we have the
ethanol and then in the presence of a
catalyst we're going to yield after our
reaction some ethene and some water and
then we have some metrics on the actual
reaction a student added a zero point
two zero zero gram sample of of ethene
of ethanol this is the ethanol c2h5oh to
a test tube using the setup shown above
so this is the glass wool with ethanol
so the ethanol is right over here
there's a solid catalyst right over
there the student heated the test tube
gently with a Bunsen burner until all of
the ethanol evaporated and gas
generation stopped so here you see the
heating all of the ethanol here
evaporates the gas generation stops when
the reaction stopped the volume of gas
collected was 0.085 four liters at 0.8
to two atmospheres and 305 Kelvin the
vapor pressure of water at 305 Kelvin is
thirty five point seven
Torr so you have is the you in the
presence of the catalyst you have the
ethanol it's going to react
it's a dehydration it's a dehydration
reaction right over here so you're going
to produce ethene and water and so you
cool it down and so the ethene gets
captured at the top it's going to be in
a gaseous state the water it's going to
be water vapor but then of course it's
once you cool it down you're going to
have liquid you're going to have liquid
water here as well so let's let's try to
answer their questions calculate the
number of moles of ethene one that are
act
produced in the experiment and measured
in the gut in the gas collection tube
and - that would be produced if the
dehydration reaction went to completion
Part B calculate the percent yield of
ethene in the experiment all right so
let's tackle part 1 let's tackle part
one first and so somehow we have to
figure out the we have to figure out the
actual moles producing the experiment
and measured in the gas collection tube
so what do they tell us here they said
until all of the ethanol evaporating gas
generation stopped when the reaction
stopped the volume of gas so this volume
of gas so this is our volume of gas
right over here that's where our ethene
is our volume of gas was 0.08 5 4 liters
so let me underline that at 0.8 - 2
atmospheres so that's the total pressure
there the temperature is 305 Kelvin and
then they give us the vapor pressure of
water is 35 point 7 at 305 Kelvin it's
35.7 Torr so the vapor pressure of water
you could view that as the partial
pressure of water and the reason why
that's useful is the partial pressure of
water plus the partial pressure of the
ethene is going to add up to the total
pressure here and so we can use that
information to figure out the partial
pressure of the ethene so the partial
pressure of the ethene and if we know
the partial pressure of the ethene well
then we could use the ideal gas law to
figure out how many moles of ethene how
many moles of ethene are actually right
over here how can we do that well just a
little reminder of the ideal gas law we
have pressure and if we're talking about
one particular thing we're here we'd be
talking about the partial pressure of
ethene times volume they give us the
volume right over here is equal to the
number of moles times the gas constant
times the temperature well we have the
pressure we have or we can be able to
figure it out we have the volume we have
the gas constant you don't have to
memorize these things that right over
here I copied and pasted what they give
you at the front
of the actual AP exam so that you don't
have to memorize these constants and
things like that so we have the the gas
constant and we have it in different
units depending which one we want to use
and then of course the temperature they
give it to us it is 305 Kelvin so if we
want to figure out the number of moles
right over here you can divide both
sides by RT and so you could say n is
equal to is equal to R sorry n egos
equal to we divide both sides if we
divide both sides by RT we're going to
get P V and I'll say the partial
pressure of ethene the partial pressure
of ethene times the volume times the
volume over over R times T over R times
T and so let's figure out everything
over here so what is going to be the
partial pressure of the ethene well the
pressure of the partial pressure of the
ethene is going to be equal to the total
pressure the total pressure minus the
partial pressure or you could say the
vapor pressure of the water the partial
pressure of the partial pressure of the
water so this is going to be equal to
our total pressure is zero point eight
two two atmospheres zero point eight two
two atmospheres now what's the pressure
of what's the partial pressure of the
water they tell us the vapor pressure of
water at 305 Kelvin is thirty five point
seven
Torr well they gave us the total
pressure in atmospheres so we have to
convert from we have to convert from
Tour's two atmospheres if we want to
stay in atmospheres so I'll do it over
here so the pressure the pressure of the
partial pressure of the water is equal
to thirty five point seven tor which is
a unit of pressure but if we want to
convert it to atmospheres once again
you'd have to memorize these things they
give it to you on the test they tell us
one atmosphere is 760 Torr so we want to
get rid of the tour we want to get rid
of the tour and we want it in terms of
atmospheres so one atmosphere is 760
Torr
so this is going to be equal to thirty
five point seven divided by seven
hundred and sixty so it's this is a
total pressure minus the partial
pressure of the water let's see the
partial pressure of the water let me
figure this out it is going to be thirty
five point seven tor times one
atmosphere for every six hundred 760
Torr so I'll just divide by 760 divided
by 760 is equal to and I have three
significant digits here so zero point
zero four seven zero zero point zero
four seven zero so this is going to be
zero point zero four seven zero
atmospheres so let me write that down so
partial the total pressure minus the
partial pressure of the water zero point
zero four seven zero atmospheres is
going to be equal to is going to be
equal to so let me just take my well I
could just make that a negative and then
add it to the total pressure so plus
plus point eight to two or zero point
eight to two is going to be equal to so
the partial pressure of our ethene three
significant digits here is going to be
seven seven five zero point seven seven
five so zero point seven seven five and
so now we can substitute that in we know
everything to figure out the number of
moles n is going to be equal to zero
point seven seven five the unit's here
are atmospheres we can always check to
make sure that we get that right
atmospheres times our volume well they
tell us our value it's zero point zero
eight five four liters 0.08 five four
liters and then we divide that by RT now
which version of our do we use well
we're dealing with atmospheres moles and
Kelvin so we could use we could use this
right over here if we were converted
everything to tour
would use this this constant but so RR
is going to be 0.08206 they're giving us
more significant digits it doesn't hurt
to use them but later we have to just
realize that our that we're going to
convert to only three significant digits
because that's that's the minimum that's
what we have these are three three this
is more than three significant is four
significant digits but let's just make
sure the units work out so this is going
to be so this is the units here are
liters times atmosphere and so those
will count will cancel with these
divided by we have to remember this is
in this is in the denominator right over
here divided by Mol's times Kelvin and
we multiply that times the temperature
which is 305 Kelvin 305 Kelvin and we'll
see we could see that well this
atmospheres is going to cancel with that
atmosphere as that leader is going to
cancel with that leaders this Kelvin is
going to cancel with that Kelvin and so
you're in the denominator you're
dividing by moles so that's not going to
be the same thing as just having moles
as your units and so this is all going
to be equal to we deserve a little bit
of a we deserve a little bit of a
drumroll here this is equal to so zero
zero point seven seven five atmospheres
times point zero eight five four liters
divided by point zero eight two zero six
so that gets us that and then we're
going divided by 305 we still have that
in the denominator divided by 305 is
equal to and if we do three significant
digits it's zero point zero zero two six
four so this is approximately I could
say zero point zero zero two six four
two six four moles and I write that
right I have a bad memory zero point
zero zero two six for you I rounded down
to two six four moles and there you have
it that's part one the ACT the number of
moles of ethane that
actually producing the experiment and
measured in the gas collection tube